bienvenue dans ce studio puisque vous
l'inaugurer aussi donc j'espère vous en
fera bon usage
quoi de mieux que david abiker pour
donner vie à un studio radio
ce journaliste d'europe 1 a eu l'honneur
d'inaugurer le nouveau bâtiment de
l'école audiovisuel troisième surtout le
le vrai plaisir c'est d'être avec les
étudiants et de voir à quel point ils se
sont donné du mal pour faire une
émission on retrouve des ambiances un
peu potache
ces insolents c'est rigolo on se plante
on recommence
voilà vive la vie quoi de beaux lots de
rides au travail voyant pour commencer
rejoint le prélude de bach que nous
avons laissé à la dernière leçon
chronique culturelle flash infos
interviewes les étudiants en journalisme
ont livré une émission radio d'une heure
trente un exercice pourtant pas évident
c'est dur quand on n'est pas en direct
et quand une émission n'est pas sous
tension de l'immédiat et de la nécessité
de faire de la bonne radio mais là on a
trouvé
je crois qu'il s'est installé un climat
qui était sympathique et pourtant il n'y
avait pas des millions d'auditeurs on
n'était pas en direct mais on était
ensemble avec ses douze mille mètres
carrés troisième est considéré comme le
plus grand campus audiovisuel d'europe
le chantier initié en 2013 a coûté plus
de 3 millions d'euros et met à
disposition des mille étudiants du
campus de nombreux moyens techniques
on a déjà un studio télé on a une salle
de projection fin de salles de cinéma de
300 places on a des studio de motion
capture et il nous manquait quelque
chose qui peut aider les journalistes à
prendre leur métier c'est un vrai studio
radio avec une régie un plateau pour
s'entraider à ce métier là les
programmes enregistrés et m 24 heures
sur 24 sur la web radio de l'école que
l'on peut retrouver sur leur site ou sur
applications mobiles